well as far as bear attacks it basically  said don't do what you suggested don't  try to run from the bear  the grizzly bear that is uh because no  one's trying it  they said they can run as fast as a  horse  and they'll catch you it doesn't it it  just doesn't matter it's it's the um  it's the juice shake and bake barry  sanders could evade  a grizzly bear yeah i bet so i bet and  it's very centered you could tackle it  grizzly bear well i'll use a running  back now if you get but you tell me  though he couldn't tackle it  he told me bears henders couldn't tackle  it come on  come on sound like a guy if you slurred  that dude  sounded like an old drunk dusty  are you drunk